being a CEO or an entrepreneur isn't
something that you typically say that
you want to be when you grow up when
you're younger people want to be
basketball players or like models
because it's not very glamorous to be a
CEO
but we're proving that like it can be
fun and like you can just be like a
normal person
I'm Erin and I'm Amelia and we run shop
cheating together and best friends so I
started shop Jean in my college dorm
room in 2012 and I was working retail
job and just like kind of frustrated
there wasn't anything like very cool and
for my taste
online to shop at so shop D who's Warren
we were really early to using Instagram
and I like contribute a lot of our
success to Instagram started using it in
2012 when not that many brands or people
or even on it if you scroll past one of
our products you're stood on the explore
page looks so eye-popping and catchy
that like people definitely like engage
with it and we're really active on our
own personal social media like Instagram
we use a lot and yeah we just put like
our kind of our whole lives out there
and I think our customers and fans like
to relate to us on there then 2012 I
started job Jean and then me like him on
January 2013 yeah so me and Erin met
years ago we crossed paths interning
Alexander Wang when we like real fashion
right you read each other's mind yeah
other sentences we sleep in this bed
together yeah awesome to be like yeah
business partners sisters best friends
low-key lovers it's almost three years
now and we're not sick of each other yet
which is pretty crazy the first thing
that we produce in the house ourselves
is a line called Netgear 90 and it's an
internet inspired really cool clothing
and accessories line the aesthetic of
Netgear 90 is just like internet
everything it's inspired by tumblr
there's lots of like baseball caps with
like reblog symbols and you know shirts
say yes daddy
things like that if I describe my
personal style it would be hardcore
poser I love this shirt
I'm retired do-it-yourself obnoxious
annoying I'm wearing a really cool
double XL dinosaur hoodies ignorant fun
edgy - be like thirsty for attention
probably and these things are pretty
cool really should take them on the
plane yeah
we will click such idiots everyone will
love it perfect our style changes like
so constantly because we like know about
things before they're big we like also
discard them like very quickly we're
like you we just saw it like on this
person darling everywhere is possible
and more yeah and it's fun it's fun we
like dressing fun people I feel like
know that we have a sense of humor and
understand like pop culture and the
internet and stuff we definitely get
people all the time we don't take us
seriously because I mean look at us
we're in a bed full of pillows the fact
that we are very nonchalant and true to
ourselves we don't change for anyone
like I will wear this to any meeting
with any investor or anyone there's no
one I wouldn't wear this outfit to if
that offends you then I don't think that
we should work together the best part
about running this business is the
connection that we have with our
customers we get comments on Instagram
all the time people saying that we have
like changed their lives but they don't
feel like they belong and that when they
come to our website they feel like
someone understands them and to think
about what we're doing in that way that
it's like inspiring people and like
really talking those lives and making
them more comfortable with who they are
able to express themselves through style
and like fit in and like feel like it's
okay to they are like that is the most
rewarding thing at the end of the day I
hands down there's a rumor that we're
lesbians on the Internet
oh so dramatic